heute fragen wir mal was sich
wahrscheinlich gerade viele Menschen
fragen bleibt das jetzt so mit der AFD
oder wird das noch schlimmer 21 Prozent
bundesweit und neuerdings 32 Prozent in
Brandenburg für eine angeblich
patriotische Partei deren
außenpolitische Ideen klingen als würden
sie in Moskau geschrieben ja werden Sie
wahrscheinlich auch
meine Theorie das das juckt die Fans
aber gar nicht ne im Moment reicht es
völlig als AFD zu sagen wir sind nicht
die Ampel und wir hassen die Grünen
fertig mehr braucht's nicht mehr braucht
es nicht
andererseits sind Umfragen eben keine
Wahl meine Damen und
bei aller Freude am gruseln muss es
jetzt wirklich stündlich eine neue
Sonntagsfrage geben ja AFD steigt in den
neuesten Umfragen auf Höchstwerte ein
Rekord hoch weiter im Höhenflug einen
neuen Höchstwert AFD im Umfrage hoch AFD
im Aufwind wie schafft sie das woher
kommt der Rechtsruck bei den deutschen
Wäldern
gute Frage ja das finde ich auch ich
meine das Erfolgsgeheimnis von denen ist
doch längst gelüftet man nehme eine
Ampel die sich monatelang selber zerlegt
und nur soft und seit gestern Freunde
eine CDU die Gesetze in Thüringen zur
Not auch mit dem Faschisten höcke
durchbringen komplizierte
Mehrheitsverhältnisse hin oder her es
ist der nächste Dammbruch die Operation
Normalisierung läuft und die AFD die
immer radikaler wird dringend trotzdem
weiter vor in bürgerliche Milieus und
zwar mit sogenannter metapolitik achten
darauf man sagt im Wahlkampf eben nicht
raus aus der NATO was nachweislich
mehrere AFD Landesverbände wollen
sondern wieder oben zwingen euch zu
Gendern und gesundes
Zeugnisse sie wollen uns die
Schweinshaxe die Bratwurst das Schnitzel
Fabien und ich kann euch sagen ich lasse
mir nicht mein Schnitzel wegnehmen
ich will überhaupt nicht an dein
Schnitzel kannst du behalten dass
dieselbe Frau gerade den 8 mai 45 den
Tag der Befreiung als Tag der Niederlage
bezeichnet hat geht da im
schnitzelrausch fast schon unter genau
wir furchtbares Gerede vom Schuldkult
Teile der AFD Blase kannst du damit eh
nicht mehr shoppen wenn überhaupt
erreicht man die indem man ruhig erklärt
was passieren würde wenn Deutschland zum
Beispiel aus der EU austritt und das
wollen sie ja natürlich sie wollen
austreten Bernd höcke bernd hat gesagt
diese EU muss sterben damit das wahre
Europa leben kann natürlich wollen die
den Weg sind das konnte man auf dem
letzten Parteitag durchaus zwischen den
Zeilen hören
gleich und sofort fertig vielen Dank
ja dafür nicht ja und das sprechende
Testbild das wir gerade gesehen haben
steht auf Listenplatz 4 kommt also
sicher ins EU-Parlament und ich will sie
jetzt wirklich nicht mit Details
langweilen aber die Folgen eines
deutschen eu-austritts wären
katastrophal für Industrie Arbeitsplätze
und Wohlstand trotzdem verweisen
afd-politiker auf das Vorbild
Großbritannien was übersetzt heißt wir
brauchen hier dringend mehr Suppenküchen
ich meine überleg doch mal denken ist
immer drüber nach Deutschland ohne EU so
ein Wahnsinn was Liebe da übrigland
es ist doch kein Wunder das
Wirtschaftsverbände eindringlich vor der
AFD waren ist der Partei aber völlig
wumpe denn sie hat halt eigene Pläne für
Europa
schlagen und ich sage dabei nur Ursula
von der Leyen ja
ein Charmeur der ganz alten Schule was
wäre gut offiziell und auf dem Papier
hat der Parteitag beschlossen einen Bund
europäischer Nationen neu zu gründen
aber alle wissen was gemeint ist Texas
genau Maximilian Krach der
Spitzenkandidat für Europa sagt wörtlich
wir müssen der EU den Stecker ziehen der
Herr krass in einen Begriff oder ja das
ist der mit diesen prägnanten
Seitenscheitel ja und
den echt frischen Ideen für sozial
Schwache Mitbürger von wegen die AFD ist
eine neoliberale Partei die zu wenig für
die Armen tut und wenn den sozial
Schwachen unter uns was auch nach der
kulturellen linken Hegemonie leider die
Regel ist keine Märchen mehr vorgelesen
und keine Lieder mehr vorgesungen würden
so wissen wir doch er Herz würde tanzen
wenn es deutsche Märchen und deutsche
Lieder werden wie man den vorträgt
also wenn mein Herz zu tanzen anfängt
ruft meine Frau hoffentlich den Notarzt
also
okay die afd-fraktion wollte neulich
erst Langzeitarbeitslose zu sogenannter
Bürgerarbeit zwingen Zwangsarbeit aber
dafür liest man ihn Märchen vor ist doch
auch schön also natürlich nur spezielle
AFD mehrchen wie das haben wir da die
Bremer stadtasylanten werden abgeschoben
dann natürlich der gespringerstiefelte
Kater äh Aladin und die Wunderlampe
zurück im sicheren Herkunftsland und
natürlich das Mädchen mit den
Schwefelhölzern erfriert im Schneeball
Robert habe hier die Ölheizung
rausgerissen hat oh ja das ist die große
Frage wie sehen Deutschland unter
afd-regierung aus zum Beispiel mit viel
weniger Zuwanderung in unseren
Arbeitsmarkt nicht gut so viel ist mal
sicher meine wo kriegt man dann die
ganzen Fachkräfte her
bitte selber machen und das musste
Anspruch einer Industrie Nation wie
Deutschland mit 84 Millionen Einwohnern
sein aus eigener Kraft heraus mit
unserem Nachwuchs auch wieder die
Fachkräfte generieren können da wäre
eine Menge zu leisten denn insgesamt
fehlen uns bis 20 60 Millionen
Arbeitskräfte die man dann eben
irgendwie folgendes sagen
einfach damit anfangen
einfach mal anfangen natürlich natürlich
nicht lang schnacken schnackseln Freunde
schakunala und ich habe gehört wenn man
dabei an den obi-biber denkt wird es
garantiert ein Handwerker
hier neuer afd-spot
ich glaube ich habe gar kein Geld mehr
bestellt ich komme im Auftrag der
Alternative für Deutschland ich soll mit
ihnen jemanden Zeugen der hier in 20
Jahren ein Rohr verlegen kann
[Musik]
deutschland braucht Fachkräfte
[Applaus]
kräftemangel bekämpfen gut und
schön aber dazu gehören immer noch zwei
gerade im Osten fehlen ja massiv Frauen
wissen Sie was macht man also um
trotzdem da eine abzukriegen stellt sich
vor Maximilian K weiß auch das jeder
dritte junge Mann hatte noch nie eine
Freundin du gehörst dazu Schau keine
Pornos will nicht die Grünen geh raus an
die frische Luft steht dir echte Männer
sind rechts echte Männer haben ideale
echte Männer sind Patrioten Freunde
ach so wussten sie das frische Luft und
recht sein darauf stehen die Frauen wenn
ich das mit 15 gewusst hätte verdammt
und ich dachte immer die AFD ist eine
rassistische total menschenverachtende
Partei eigentlich ist das eine
Partnervermittlung
Martin Klemme ist der AFD dating Coach
[Musik]
ter deutscher Männer euer erbärmliches
Single-Leben hat aber jetzt seit Ende
ich kotz euch erstmal ordentlich durch
Tipp Nummer eins vergiss dein Aussehen
du kannst hässlich sein wie ein Hund
Hack hauptsache du bist rechts hier
der Alex zum Beispiel ja das sind totale
Wurst praktisch und vermittelbar den
würden die meisten Frauen noch nicht mal
der Kneifzange anfassen halt's Maul aber
das macht nichts denn selbst so ein
Krieg ich auf rechts gezogen
so jetzt sieht er ja fast aus wie ein
Mensch der Kamera
ein bisschen Tomaten
hier drin hat er gleich seine ersten
Dates
sag mal was soll das Gemüse da ich
dachte Frauen mögen Blumen
halt dich gerade schön dass wir uns
jetzt endlich mal getroffen haben du
studierst Lehramt voll interessant
wusstest du eigentlich dass die Polen
den Zweiten Weltkrieg
angefangen haben
wenn ich dir ein Kompliment machen darf
du hast ein sehr
gebärfreudiges Becken
lass uns doch später zu mir
gehen und Fachkräfte zeigen
sehr scheiße vorgetragen mach dir mal
keinen Kopf junge selbst ich kriege ich
vermittelt
gerade hat mich der Alex angerufen er
hat jetzt tatsächlich eine Freundin
seine erste moment mal was ist denn das
das ist die Manfred aus meiner
Wehrsportgruppe sie identifiziert sich
seit gestern als Frau
Martin klempnerhofer der AFD Edinburg
so meine Damen und Herren es gibt aber
auch noch ein paar gute Nachrichten für
dieses gebeutelte Land Rudi Völler hat
uns
alle Geräte
leider nur für ein Spiel aber immerhin
das macht doch wieder Hoffnung vor der
Euro 24 die übrigens ich weiß gar nicht
ob ihnen das bewusst ist den perfekten
Sponsoring-Partner hat den Konzern der
wie kein anderer für Erfolg made in
Germany steht richtig die Deutsche Bahn
meine Damen und ja das
passt doch denn Bahn fahren geht ja auch
oft in die Verlängerung deswegen
war es für Rudis 11 auch quasi
Ehrensache zum Frankreich Spiel den ICE
zu nehmen der angepaltete Zug war
ausgefallen und so ist das DFB-Team am
Tag nach der Entlassung von Hansi fliegt
jetzt mit dem Bus nach Dortmund gefahren
natürlich unfassbar oder so bis jetzt
habe ich gedacht diese Deutsche Bahn
könnte nicht mal Rudi Völler retten aber
von wegen pünktlich zum Tag der Schiene
der ist nämlich heute verkündet der
Konzern das größte Sanierungsprogramm
seiner Geschichte und Verkehrsminister
Volker Wissing sagt sinngemäß wir
schaffen das oder so ähnlich ja ja ist
wirklich toll 12,5 Milliarden zusätzlich
durch eigenkapitalerhöhung insgesamt 40
Milliarden Plus um unser Bahnnetz
Schritt für Schritt auf den Stand eines
zivilisierten Landes zu bringen und als
wir uns dann die Entwicklung angeschaut
haben der letzten Jahre haben wir
festgestellt dass es schlechter statt
besser geworden ist und das bedeutet ja
nichts Gutes
völlig richtig völlig richtig ist oft
kein gutes Zeichen so und damit haben
Volker Wissing und die Ampel schon mal
deutlich mehr für die Bahn getan als die
ganzen furchtbaren csu-heinz die seinen
Job vorher hatten nicht zuletzt den
verdanken wir den sagen wir mal musealen
Zustand unseres Bahnnetzes es ist ja so
es ist ja so man hat man hat alles so
lange vergammeln lassen bis nur noch
Neubau hilft denn den hat der Bund
bezahlt und nicht der Konzern weil wie
so ein Anreiz zum rosten lassen wurde
jetzt endlich mal geändert es war
nämlich Achtung höchste Eisenbahn meine
Damen und Herren denn ARD Recherchen
zeigen Bahn fahren ist manchmal nicht
nur nervig sondern unter Umständen sogar
gefährlich ein Beispiel als letztes Jahr
bei Garmisch ein Zug entgleiste waren
hinterher nicht alle überrascht
Lokführer die oft auf der Strecke
unterwegs sind haben sofort einen
Verdacht und liegt deren whatsapp-chat
vor wir wissen alle in welchem Zustand
diese Strecke ist
ab Tutzing ist alles im Arsch also quasi
wirklich richtig im Arsch ja ab Tutzing
ist alles im Arsch es klingt wie ein
ganz schlimmer Hit von Mickie Krause ja
so und wie schlimm die Lage ist zeigt
der sogenannte netzzustandsbericht darin
gibt man sich selbst für alle Gleise
weichen und Stellwerke im Schnitt die
Note 3 so und wenn Sie jetzt denken wow
im Abi wäre ich froh gewesen bei der
Bahn steht Note 3 für relativ kurze
voraussichtliche Restlebensdauer
soll ich hier den üblichen Witz über ZDF
Zuschauer machen nein diesmal nicht muss
ich nicht muss ich nicht okay
2022 hat das Verkehrsministerium in
Berlin erstmals marode Zustände
eingeräumt ja hier die neue Bahncard
fifty fifty weil das die Chancen sind ob
man ankommt also überspitz gesagt
überspitzt ausgedrückt aber hey meine
dafür sind sie richtig gut improvisieren
wenn zum Beispiel mal so eine Schranke
kaputt geht wie diese hier im August 22
seit damals sperren nun zwei
Schrankenwärter mit einem Flatterband
den Bahnübergang Tat und Nacht an die
120 mal täglich
[Musik]
ein krisenfester Job würde ich sagen ja
ich hoffe die beiden haben studiert kann
man da nur sagen ja seit heute also
sowas wie Licht am Ende des unsanierten
Tunnels es wird aber leider erst mal
schlimmer werden bevor es besser wird 40
sogenannte hoch belastete Strecken
sollen nämlich in den nächsten sieben
Jahren für ungefähr fünf Monate gesperrt
komplett gesperrt dafür aber auch mal
komplett saniert werden viel Spaß Liebe
Pendler aber es geht nicht anders es
geht nicht anders das passiert wenn man
das so lange vor sich herschieben heißt
auch in den nächsten Jahren bleibt Bahn
fahren in Deutschland sowas wie das
letzte Abenteuer
sie nennen es die härteste Challenge der
Welt 7 vs wild 7 Abenteurer werden in
der Wildnis ausgesetzt und müssen
irgendwie überleben was für eine Weichei
Scheiße denn jetzt kommt die ultimative
Herausforderung sieben Pendler werden
morgens auf dem Bahnhof in Mettmann
ausgesetzt und müssen es nach Duisburg
schaffen die nur eine Woche Sachen
schon nach drei Sekunden liegen die
Nerven blank
deutsche Regionalbahn survival of the
fittest
Falken um jeden Sitzplatz
und dann natürlich Signalstörung und
zugavarie nach zwei Tagen am Rand der
Bahnstrecke wird das Essen knapp okay
[Applaus]
ja jetzt die Frage wie viel Reform
braucht diese Bahn die
monopol-kommission des Bundes schlägt
vor den DB-Konzern zu zerschlagen das
Bahnnetz vom Zugbetrieb zu trennen dazu
begrüße ich nun Mandy hausten für die
Linkspartei im Verkehrsausschuss Mandy
könnte diese Idee der monopol-kommission
die Marke retten also das ist aber
wirklich mal eine sehr
dumme Frage mein lieber wurstgesichtiger
Freund
die Marke DB ist doch komplett verbrannt
da kann ich genauso gut fragen wie mache
ich Nagelpilz wieder populär unter den
Wendler es geht nicht weg damit
Wiedersehen mein Vorschlag wir erklären
die Privatisierung offiziell für
gescheitert und der ganze Bums heißt ab
sofort wieder Deutsche Reichsbahn DDR es
war nicht alles schlecht danke schön
ich war nicht dabei bei euch war denn
die waren so viel besser in der DDR
nicht sagen also die Züge hinter der
Erde sind im Schnitt so 50 kmh gefahren
die Toiletten waren in einem
enkelhaften Zustand und jedes geöffnete
mit Roboter Restaurant war eine
Sensation kurz gesagt wie heute der
letzte scheiß aber es war unser scheiß
Oliver böse sein scheiß heute ist die
sogenannte ah okay muss ich vielleicht
kurz übersetzen steht für arschgeburt
ich denke Aktiengesellschaft wenn du
denkst du denkst dann denkst
ST du pünktlich und bezahlbar sonst
nichts
bahnfahren ist da seins Vorsorge kennst
du Oliver
daseinsvorsage das heißt ab und zu soll
mal ein Zug da sein
habe ich einen kleinen Job gemacht
wenn sie mal Gewinne machen würden wenn
die mit ihren Zügen über 30 Milliarden
Schulden allein Stuttgart 21 kostet wohl
über 10 Milliarden also viermal so viel
wie geplant da streiten sich jetzt
Baden-Württemberg und die Bahn vor
Gericht wer die Mehrkosten trägt ich
kann ja mal speichern wer die am Ende
diese ganzen hilfsätze hier sitzen darum
und gucken wie eine Kugel ins Bett
manches versteht man wirklich nicht
meine der Bund ist alleiniger DB
Eigentümer hat aber wohl nur einen
begrenzten Einfluss warum eigentlich
weil er blöd ist und deshalb holen wir
die Reichsbahn zurück wo ich übrigens
meinen letzten Job vor der Wende hatte
als Schaffnerin ich habe sogar noch die
original Uniform soll ich sie dir mal
zeigen nee das ist eigentlich gar nicht
nötig
sowas von irgendwas
[Applaus]
soll ich dich mal kontrollieren du
willst
das schöne Gesicht das Sozialismus das
war ich und weißt du was mein gutster
bei meiner letzten Schicht 1990 da habe
ich das Original schicken
und das darfst du kleiner Glückspilz
jetzt probieren
das ist wirklich super lieb aber ich
mache gerade intervallfasten und äh
Schranke hoch der Tee zukommt
schaut euch gerne weitere Videos an und
abonniert den Kanal danke
oh nein eine Zeitschleife habt ihr etwa
nicht den Kanal abonniert Hilfe sofort
draufklicken oder ich bin hier für immer
schaut euch gerne weitere Videos an